„Servus, ich bin der Bonzo. Die Welt ist voll verrückt!
Mein Geschäft ist komplett am Arsch. Ich habe so gut verdient, weißt?
Mit flache Fernseh'. Auf einmal braucht kein Mensch mehr flache Fernseh'
Jeder hat schon flache Fernseh'.
Brauch ich wieder neue Geschäftsidee.
Und bis ich habe eine neue Geschäftsidee, mach ich das hier, weißt?
Bin ich ganz oben angekommen.
Bei mir laufen die Fäden zusammen.
Da bin ich bei die Bayerische Fundrunk, weißt?
Da bin ich so eine Art Chef!“
„Sie, Herr Bonzo, die Gesamtausgaben für Bleistifte und Radiergummis, die müssten Sie nochmal neu zusammenzählen.
Sie haben da ein paar Kommas übersehen.“
„Okay! Kommas sind total wichtig.
Ich scheiß doch die Komma an.“
„Wie bitte?“
„Nichts, andere Frage: Brauchst du flache ...?“
„Schnauze!“
„Alles klar!
Eine Komma, zwei Komma, ...“